[Music]
Stephanie bissonnette who played high
school student Don Schweitzer in Mean
Girls the musical has died she was 32
years old
[Music]
the Broadway production announced the
sad news on Twitter writing that their
hearts are broken quote she filled our
theater with her laughter and friendship
inspired us with her fighting spirit and
bravery and gray star stage with the
fiercest Talent Broadway has ever known
[Music]
all right
the statement went on adding that you
will be missed profoundly before
encouraging everyone to do something
they love today in Stephanie's honor
Stephanie was a part of the Broadway
company from the first performance in
2018 to the last in 2020 and while a
cause of death has yet to be revealed
according to playbill Stephanie was
previously diagnosed with a rare form of
brain cancer in 2019 but after
undergoing treatment she was able to
return to the show and resume performing
[Music]
following the news of her death fellow
mean girls the musical Alum Ashley Park
posted a lengthy heartfelt tribute to
Instagram writing that her friend's life
was nothing short of a Triumph and
watching Stephanie fight to the end has
been one of the greatest honors of her
life it's worth noting Ashley is a
cancer survivor and recently opened up
about her journey on today with Hoda and
Jenna I was 15 you want to not have
anything to find you that's right and I
really didn't want to have I wanted to
one day be on a talk show and have long
hair and nobody would have any idea I
had cancer you know but I think that
attitude has really informed the person
that I am today in that same interview
Ashley gave a shout out to Stephanie
just days before her death my friend
Stephanie she's battling and fighting
for her life right now and she performed
with me and Mean Girls so please
in addition to her role in Mean Girls
the musical Stephanie helped choreograph
for the muni Riverside Theater
Shakespeare Theater Company and seven
Angel Cedar she also appeared in music
videos including Keith Urban's never
coming down
coming back